hey was soll ich das video machen roger
faxon herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen
video aus dem urlaub in österreich ja
das ganze setting ist bisschen ruhiger
dies kann auf meinem balkon und da unten
ist die straße und da laufen ungefähr 20
milliarden leute pro stunde vorbei das
letzte reaction video leute über bibi
hat sich richtig richtig gut gefallen
das hat mir damals schon 300.000 aufrufe
deswegen dachte ich mir okay wisst ihr
was ich habe zwischenzeitlich wieder
etwas entdeckt was einfach so scheiße
ist und dachte mir dazu mache ich noch
meine reaktion
die ganze geschichte fängt damit an dass
ich ein tweet von david hain gesehen
habe der tweet lautete merken dinge mit
dem heißen messer schneiden geht gerade
in den usa viral heiß ab nächsten monat
dann in youtube deutschland und leute
leute
es hat keine drei tage gedauert und es
wurde auch in deutsche kopiert und von
keinem geringeren als unserem
geschätzten herrn april ist es halt
mittlerweile sogar müsste ich einfach
nur die dümmsten trends in amerika als
schauen diese color blind videos die
1000 gradmesser zerschneiden videos mit
ihr könnt sicher sein
innerhalb von einer woche wird auch ab
ob das video macht es ist heute ist
schon eine form der hellseherei aber
jetzt schauen wir uns die ganze scheiße
hier mal an bevor ich wieder starten
würde ich eine kleine anregung groß an
eine große kleine unter wird am sonntag
um 830 diese kaste schule wir sind alle
präsentiert das wirklich alle von vorne
bis hinten alles gezeigt hatten wir
nicht schon mal das thema mit apparat
und der scharfstellung seiner kamera das
hatten wir doch schon mal oder ich weiß
nicht ob mein laptop ich gerade täuscht
aber es sieht aus als hätte das immer
noch nicht hinbekommen einfach mal seine
kamera scharf zu stellen wir wollen die
ganze scheiß wie du ihn voll
auch die ganzen scheiß wie es empfohlen
ist kann ich nachvollziehen
okay soweit hast du mich jetzt hier
weiter und zwar wie jemand einfach mit
einem ultra heißen
dem messer einfach ne cola zerschneidet
das video nicht gesehen und das video
wird einfach relativ einfach
funktionieren perversen brenner wird ein
messer so hart erhitzt das ist richtig
gehütetes video noch nicht gesehen aber
weiß schon wie das messer in dem video
erhitzt wird
das ist nicht schlecht billige leute
diese mister gier videos ja ihr habt die
bestimmt auch schon gesehen gerade so
was von ab es ist nicht in worte zu
fassen wie diese scheiß videos abgeben
nach fünf tagen 30 millionen views nach
18 stunden 9 millionen views sind
komplett gestört die dinge und
selbstverständlich leute wenn man
aufgrund der tatsache dass man selbst
nicht erhält dem kopf ist die
berechtigte annahme und befürchtung hat
dass man alle umbringen würde wenn man
selbst im experiment hat schaut man sich
natürlich lieber die experimente aus dem
sicheren wohnen zwar sehr gutes übrigens
verlinken und ich glaub er welche
mehrere sachen angreifen
hat er das ding nicht mal geschnitten
als dem ordner fragt sieht einfach
wirklich so aus als würde sie einfach
wirklich nur hinsetzen die dinger nicht
mal schneiden sowie ging es damals in
amerika zogen allerdings kennt was
letztes gemacht hat es hat sich
hingesetzt und hat sich die videos
angeschaut okay wenn man sie denn auch
gescheit schneidet meinetwegen aber wenn
man die nicht mal scheiden
handseife original handseife freunde
original original hat so er fertig
ich stelle für damen und kriegt jetzt
stichstelle vor dem aus steht und kommt
es dass ich so wirklich angehört aber
ich kann schon nachvollziehen so diese
videos sind schon echt ist eigentlich
schon recht interessanten sich sagen
also zugucken wie so ein heißes messer
dinge durchschaut ist schon spannend
aber es ist halt ultra billiger konnte
und er kann nicht nur so wie ich sagen
dass ich wenn ich zum beispiel babys
videos schaue da seine videos schaue ich
irgendwas kritisieren damit irgendwas
lustig mache sondern bei ihnen das ist
wirklich einfach nur schaut sie aber
wieder an und das ist nur scheinbar
wirklich nicht geschnitten jetzt käse
durch irgendwas muss da passieren diese
bibliothek oder jetzt kommt die
colaflasche viele unfassbar unfassbar
was macht ihr denn noch in diesem jahr
muss dann noch irgendwas anderes machen
hier alle die ganze die colaflasche
misshandelt
stell dir eigentlich nicht diesem scheiß
video mann wenn er direkt schwarzer
heute
die chips sind direkt schwarz wer hätte
es gibt doch wer wäre auf den
menschlichen gedanken gekommen dass
chips wenn sie kontakt mit einem 1000
grad heißen messer kommen eventuell
schwarz werden dankeschön für diese
reize und april für wie viel euro würde
sie das essen sein so führte schon dabei
nein nein
also erstmal danke für die diebe frage
dankeschön sehr unterhaltsam auch ich
würde sagen für 100 oder 200 ok als java
russisches tic tac leute es wird immer
besser dieses video wird einfach nur
besser gras fraß raster streak
braintrust it praktiker wissen wie hart
das ist die taktik glücklich was euch
dieses video machen einer fahrt im
großen und ganzen ich mache gerade
selbst auch in reaktion video ich bin
trotzdem dass meine noch bisschen was
anderes ist weil ich versuche das was
ich schaue auf die schippe zu nehmen
oder die ganze sache irgendwie anders zu
verpacken in dem ich mich darüber lustig
machen oder ironisch damit umgehe
auch als einfach macht ist er schaut
sich wirklich aber die originalen videos
an und sagt hier und da krass und für
wie viele euro wird es dir ein
abschieben und für wieviel euro wird es
deiner mutter in mund schieben
ja das ist wirklich der inhalt dieses
videos er sitzt aber da und sagt krass
er sagt dann aber krass das ist das ist
auf jeden fall gut versteht mich nicht
falsch ich weiß selbst wie schwer ist
manchmal erst auf video idee zu kommen
und dass man teilweise einfach über
jeden mist den man machen kann froh dass
man keine ideen aber so oft lädt der
wirklich nicht hoch wir können uns mal
kurz checken
er hat diese woche ein video hochgeladen
okay die woche davor hat er mehr
aufgeladen haben ein video pro woche und
wenn du ein video pro woche machst ist
das einzige mit den bohrungen kommst du
irgendein anderes video anzuschauen und
nicht mehr irgendwie noch interessant
dass kommentar dazu zu machen sondern
einfach nur krass zu sagen und zu sagen
für wie viel euro würde es euch in euren
körper auf noch einschieben
das ist großartig ich bin selbst
natürlich bisschen gefährdet dadurch
dass sie kompetent zum kommentare mache
aber leute was haltet ihr von der ganzen
sache gibt für euch ein unterschied
zwischen reagieren auf irgend video was
heißt ich schaue im video an sagt krass
und kommentare das heißt ich schaue mir
ein video an und versuche irgendwie nach
dem video nannte es zu geben die mich
anders aufziehen könnt ihr gerne mal die
kommentare schreiben und auch was sie
von diesem wunderschönen wie
gehalten habe das was wir sorry dafür
dass im lauf ist wie es dunkel wurde ich
hoffe ich kann das geschäft ausgleichen
im schnitt bis zum nächsten mal haut
rein macht's gut sein